can you set the stage for us what are we
getting today from Hillary Clinton well
we're getting a second major economic
policy address of the Clinton campaign
she gave one just a couple weeks ago
this one puts a little more meat on the
bones she is trying to as you guys said
I don't think they're saying anything
quite as grandiose as quote fixed
corporate America but and the Tyrian of
tyranny of short-termism she got four
grandiose that's pretty grandiose not
quite as quite quite as grandiose as try
to fix corporate America but politically
she's trying to hit the sweet spot
between making Democrats and those on
the Left happy and putting her in a
place where she seems as though she is
progressive but without offending people
in the business community or on Wall
Street among her donors so she's got
four basic ideas that she's putting
forward than they're they're not at this
point super detailed right we have some
guidance on the area she's going after
one is a capital gains overhaul taxation
the second changing taxation on
executive compensation the third is a
proposal to deal with raining and
activist shareholders and the fourth is
met the disclosure of stock buybacks
those are the four areas we can talk
about each of them but we don't have a
lot of detail at this point we have
guidance in terms of what she's aiming
for I'd love to focus on number three
because to my right is an activist
investor Greg first of all let's back it
up please what's your political
affiliation do you have one I mean
that's a fair question question before
we discuss this it's a fair question i'm
an independent that leans a little to
the republican party got it what's your
take on what hillary clinton's going
after today well i think certainly the
capital gains approach which she's
discussed or her campaign is discussed
and her attacks on activist investors
which seem to be coming today are ill
conceived policy and probably bad for
the economy and economic growth overall
you know she's in tempting to do i think
is to put some artificial impediments in
the way of the free flow of capital and
the free flow of investment dollars and
that seems to me to be a bad idea for
for both growth in the economy and for
capital allocation among investors you
know she wants a sliding scale for
capital gains on the face of it that
makes sense if you get in and out you
pay more capital gains if you're a
longer term investor you're rewarded
by your faith in that company and
America like for a pay by paying less
capital gains tax well you say it makes
sense but but I haven't heard the
rationale for that it sounds sounds sort
of its dixit to me I mean where did you
just say if she Dixit that means is that
what language is that I think it's Latin
I think it's Latin it means oh cuz I
said it because I said it it's true I
let me get what I like it I don't know
that because you said it seems mix which
what do you know if see Dixit in any
case sorry I mean her premise is that
you want investors in American companies
to be a longer term investors right and
I think she's dead wrong frankly that
would be because one of the mistakes
she's making is conflating the length of
time you hold the stock with your
interest in whether or not the company
does well over the long term let me
illustrate so the best way to make a
stock price move in the short term as
we're seeing today for amazon for
example is to demonstrate to
shareholders that you've got a better
business plan over the long term that's
going to produce even better profits or
but do we even give corporate CEOs the
opportunity to do that Jeff Bezos is an
outlier the chair holders have just said
I pray at the altar of Jeff Bezos and he
doesn't necessarily need to be
profitable I'm just gonna ride it out
with him while other CEOs have Carl
Icahn and Dan Loeb banging down their
door saying you need to deliver to me
yesterday and by the way after you after
I banged on your door and you fall at my
feet I may sell the stock tomorrow Allah
dan loeb Marissa Meyer he hasn't been in
yahoo in the last two and a half years
know that it may be right that they sell
the stock and by the way that I think
that's probably great for capital
allocation in the capital markets
because they're going to move on to the
next inefficient company and get them to
do improve you to make improvements
whether it's authorized sry doesn't
necessarily make improvements well one
could say Marissa Meyer has or has not
done a fantastic job but it worked out
for dan loeb look in any particular
situation obviously this can be great or
not so great but what I think the theory
here is is that if i can if i can get a
company to go from earning a dollar a
year every year for the next ten years
in in the markets expectation to earning
instead a dollar twenty a year every
year for the next ten or fifteen years
and show some growth what happens is the
stock price moves very rapidly
to the upside and you can make a lot of
money in the short term by getting the
company on a better long-term pat let's
get away from this argument about access
Fester's for a moment and let me just
ask you John about the kind of tight
road that Hillary Clinton walks here in
New York because at the same time as I'm
sure she's courting Wall Street donors
for money for her campaign campaign
she's also kind of in a way kind of
attacking at least the ideals of most
Wall Streeters on many of these points
well I think looked as a political
matter what she has on this proposal
least is the cover of Blair Efron and
the this is a proposed the capital gains
proposal is a proposal that's basically
bringing together an idea that the
center for american progress which is a
progressive left think-tank run by Neera
tanden who was her longtime policy
director with Blair efron is a private
equity investor rather a lot of Marc
Lasry from Avenue cap right so she edged
fungi and also a guy who is going to be
supportive of this proposal so there is
not uniformity I think in the investment
community about these issues there are
many people who take the position that
these things are damaging and these will
not be popular on the right there will
be some disquiet in the middle there are
though some democratic hedge fund people
private equity people and straight wall
street bankers who or you know big
supporters a person as I say this is
this has Blair efron is the kind of the
guy who gives the upon my tour of that
whole group so she's going to point to
the fact that not everyone in the
investor classes against these ideas it
seems to me that on the capital gains
from it may be less controversial than
the proposals to do with executive
compensation what the Obama
administration learned when it tried to
dabble in the question of whether the
government has a role through tax policy
and messing around with executive
compensation was that that was the
sacred cow what that there were there
are a lot of people across the spectrum
who got very upset at the notion that
the government should have anything to
do with setting with having incentivized
with changing the tax code or in any
other way getting involved in the
question of compensation that to me
seems like it could be a more
politically explosive discussion than
even the capital gains one might turn
out to be I agree with that you argue
that changing trying to change behavior
the tax code historically gives you
unintended consequences a lot of times
harmful well I think there always are
unintended consequences and these sorts
of policy decisions but but even if she
gets the intended consequence what
you'll do is stand in the way of people
moving their capital from a place they
don't think is any longer a great
opportunity for investment to some new
you know investment that they think is
much better so so it would you know
delay the development of the next uber
right or the next Twitter because the
people who would be pulling their money
from aeropostale and and taking those
you know gains or losses and moving
their money to uber to develop a new you
know taxicab service will instead pause
and think well if I wait another six or
nine months off facial tax dollars
that's all that does sound important and
we want the next uber and that's really
exciting and we want card I tell me what
I love loves I love but what she's also
trying to approach here is income
inequality and wouldn't want to argue
the the income inequality crisis that
we're facing in this country of the rich
getting exponentially richer and the
poor suffering is is possibly more
important than the next uber popping up
no I actually think the next doober
popping up an economic growth in
start-up companies and using capital to
develop new businesses is probably the
best antidote to income inequality and
the best opportunity for people to be
alloyed certainly certainly to raising
people out of poverty even if it doesn't
affect income inequality well if it was
done bring these drivers I won't I'm not
gonna advocate for Hillary Clinton's
posture on anything here I'll all I'll
say is that one of the interesting
things is that in the course of doing
doing dodd-frank and other things the
thing we heard over and over again from
investor from the investor class as it
were was that it almost doesn't matter
what the rules are as long as the rules
are clear that that essential is that
the one of the mat that that one of the
things that they would say about whether
it was regulatory reform or some of the
things that Hillary Clinton proposing is
you know the capital will find a way to
to fund innovation capital find a way
whatever the rules are if they are clear
that the market will figure will route
around problems altima tree and
ultimately and ultimately sustained in
this in this very advanced capital in a
cup
apolis economy that we live in it'll all
be okay that's that was one of the
arguments the problem with government
from some people's point of view is lack
of clarity lack of certainty right if
you have clarity and certainty the
market will figure it out I think that's
I think that's you I think that's what
she will then hey what are you we're not
very much time here and I want to ask
one quick question you mention it
doesn't matter what the rules are I'm
not I don't mean that I don't mean that
at the extreme oh but obviously there's
me and obviously there's some rules that
would be disaster they agree right and
to that to that to that extent the IGS
that called for a criminal investigation
into Hillary's email as we enjoy did it
your take on that I saw this pop up last
night and your time story this morning
and saying the 29 your email to
inspectors last night it popped up in my
mouth no I have a new york times 0 in my
email yet no i have alerts obviously set
and a is he has a server at home too yes
the big story this morning in the new
york times about the fact that two
inspectors general i'm using the proper
grammar and syntax the State Department
inspector general and the inspector
general if the intelligence agencies
have requested a criminal investigation
related to Hillary Clinton's email
practices Justice Department is not yet
decided about that but the big takeaway
now we're not that much time the big
takeaway here is this issue is not going
away for her we still don't know whether
she's actually broken the law but we're
this is ratcheting up and for anybody
who has said well this is all just a
sideshow it's not going to have any
long-term lasting political effects or
legal effects that this seems to suggest
that this issue is going to be with her
in a significant way for months to come
when she presents today do we know if
they'll be QA will she be able to stick
to her message or is this email
situation could that end up being the
real headline we get this afternoon well
she's not she's not to my knowledge
planning to do any media planning to
take questions did she give me a speech
but there's no question that in the
media environment today that this is
story could not be worse time for her
there will be a lot of there's the hope
for her to have this day to herself to
talk about these economic proposals of
hers that is now off the table because
at a minimum you have the effective
split screen now legal probably email
problems and policy issues and you guys
know how the media is the scandal will
get a lot more attention than
the earnest policy but well she has the
day to herself she just a story that
guys that's that's exactly right yes
we'll hear a lot about Hillary today
there you got excellent John thanks so
much guys going us Oh day give me come
on gibbeh oh yeah I know how to do this
one I can't even do that I can I know
how do I got nothing over here very good
no no it's fine den what I understand
yeah it's addictive yeah Laura bring the
life I bring the light I thought he said
whoopsie-daisy at first I wasn't really
sure what language that was emptied